so you can
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
perfect
[Music]
yo what's up everybody I am Thomas Toby
whatever you want to call me welcome
back to the dope as usual podcast this
is Michael it's Marty O'Neill softball
super sick sure by the way it's my goal
is Mario Neil let's get started guys
today's guest uh globally recognized
entrepreneur motivational speaker just
all around positivity Pusher I would
like to say this is Charlie Charlie rock
thank you for coming man hey man thanks
man appreciate you being here dude and
uh the earliest guest
show the matter which is great like
people are like sometimes we're waiting
like an hour later that's the that's the
manager in me I used to I used to have
to fight to get my artist there on time
and the manager and me is just like nah
we got to be early yeah so it goes a
long ways in business to be honest
people remember that stuff oh do I
remember the people that showed up late
as hell ago
or what happens when you get a paper no
like in business yeah I've been in
business meetings like you're 40 minutes
late I wanna know what's funny it's like
when we would be negotiating like record
deals and we meet with record labels
like I remember this one time I was
managing Travis Porter and uh Universal
was taking us out to Mr Charles and we
were actually like early to Mr Charles
but I was like no no no no we gotta like
stay in the Sprinter van we got to make
them like think we're like Superstars so
we're gonna walk in like 45 minutes late
like so there isn't but honestly there's
there's a strategy to it sometimes
but you never want to be late to a radio
interview
but like sometimes when somebody's
trying to sign you sometimes it's just a
little tiny better you want to be like
I'm eager as hell I need this I'm 20
minutes early I get what you're saying
man there's a little bit of strategy but
for something like this oh yeah yeah for
some big stuff yeah you have to me like
I'll I text him how far you are I'm
laying my back I'm two minutes late like
I just I don't know what's in me because
I feel rude I guess you know but um so
here we go real quick I before we
started talking and before we started
the podcast we just did the Ted talk you
just did the tech Ted Talk you were
speaker also I missed your entire speech
because I was in there pacing trying to
remember this [ __ ] and I wasn't even
listening to anybody I was like oh my
God I got to get my [ __ ] done I got to
watch it I was wrong
stage right getting ready to introduce
the next person so I got them I missed
it all so for everyone out there I I
introduced who you were but what do you
like at the core we'll get into all the
things you used to do because
just from what we've learned like well
you've had like five career paths
already and you've changed them to to
cater to what you want to do next which
is kind of [ __ ] the the goal for
everybody like I want to do that I want
to be pilot I'm going to be a pilot I'm
gonna do this I'm gonna do that so for
everyone out there what do you do right
now what is it like what's your goal
because I've seen you online training my
videographers also on the show I just
let the fans recognize when fki first
came on and attributed thank you guy to
basically rescuing him and launching his
multi-platinum career as a producer and
discovering post Malone all these other
people it was Charlie yeah this is the
Charlie was talking about that's where
he's like one day you guys try to get
him on here it just happened to work man
that's right yeah it was sick well if I
were to describe what what I am uh I
would say I would say I'm I'm that guy
on your shirt that's me
he's got his head in the clouds
absolutely I'm a dreamer my head is is
in the clouds my head is in the clouds
this morning
um like I'm in the gym and I put on my
like meditation music and I'm like going
into the future and I'm seeing
everything we're about to do and like I
could tell y'all right now like prophecy
style what's about to happen over the
next three weeks
so there's a little girl we're helping
with that has cancer and we surprised
her at the Ted Talk and so I was going
to cancel the Ted talk because I was
like insecure about my weight and stuff
because I had gained about 60 pounds and
my whole story is known for like weight
loss so it's like very like get on stage
is traumatizing but then I shifted my
focus from like me to like let's go big
and when I go big everything becomes
easier so I said there's this little
girl with cancer been fighting cancer
since she was two all she knows is the
hospital she doesn't have friends like
all she knows is the hospital and I was
like what if we what if we brought her
to life and I asked her what her
favorite select who her favorite
celebrities were she said Mr Beast and
Zendaya well we got Mr Beast to surprise
her at the Ted Talk on stage and he gave
her ten thousand dollars for her dream
business which she wants to do a
clothing line but she also wants to meet
Zendaya what she doesn't know is that
Zendaya's sister and Uncle were in the
crowd so I'm planting seeds for what's
about to happen next now I don't know
when y'all are putting this out but
hopefully she doesn't listen to it
hopefully she doesn't listen to it but
what's going to happen over the next
three weeks I'm seeing it now we're
gonna help her build a clothing line
we're going to get all the celebrities
involved we're going to do a million
dollars in sales
in in a couple weeks we're going to get
the the the the the Kardashians we're
gonna get this in days we're going to
get athletes she likes streetwear
so we're gonna do a fashion runway show
at the Dream Factory where celebrities
performers everybody
we're going to launch the website right
there after the after the fashion show
and in the fashion show there's going to
be disabled kids walking it's going to
be a powerful powerful night and we're
going to throw a pop-up shop and then
there's gonna be a line down the street
and then this little girl is going to
become world famous and then Rihanna's
gonna want her to be like a guest at the
Super Bowl like I like making people
into Stars that's always what I've been
passionate about
but here's a little girl who who the the
morning the Ted Talk I talked to her in
the morning she couldn't even answer one
of my questions she was so nervous she
would like look up to her mom for like
what should I say what should I say
she's 15 year old girl but like nervous
shy like in her shell by the end of the
night because I asked her mom I said if
I ask her to get on stage what do you
think she'll say she'll say no because
she's so shy I asked her to get on stage
she said yeah by the end of that night
she was like this that I moved my people
I saw her Blossom I caught him on the
next day she's like I don't even know
who she is I was like she just needed
the world to see her and the world's
about to see her she's gonna be a star
she's gonna have one of the biggest
clothing lines in the world in three
weeks prophecies see the thing is you're
saying will will oh well it's not like
we're gonna try or do that's the thing
we always say like no you see things
I've seen things I saw exactly what
we're gonna do because I know it will if
not I will make it work it's gonna
happen somewhere I love that so
visualization seeing things come to life
this is something using every day of
your life then absolutely for everything
absolutely and real quick when you when
you say I don't want to get up there
because I gained 60 pounds I've been
doing this bro I'm a fat dude also I
used to do uh weightlifting competitions
oh [ __ ] when I was a high school so I
was I actually rocked the [ __ ] out and
then I just got to get and then I feel
you sometimes I'll be on camera like
yeah then I gotta start doing [ __ ] so
I'm trying to
you so when you sound like damn you're
pretty open about that because I'm open
about that too like all these fat fools
out here I feel you
feel you I know what you I know that
feeling bro especially if you grew up
like that yeah it's even worse but when
you get older to a certain point you're
like no I got money now I got to do this
I'm trying to help people I gotta help
myself yeah so we watch your Nike
commercial like bro you were running
marathons and [ __ ] I remember he decided
for his first one too yeah OC Marathon
in May oh there we go yeah I'm doing New
Zealand in October wow and in Africa I
am in uh March next year can you break
down what the training's like for going
into these absolutely
um I have my own proprietary Training
Method
it's called play
because when I think about like an Iron
Man for example
there's complicated ways to go about
things and then there's real easy and
simple ways
um if you pull out an Iron Man training
program it's going to tell you all these
like things so you need to run this many
at this heart rate than this on this day
and then this and then bike on this day
and then interval this and then I'm like
forget all that let me look at the
bottom how many hours training a week on
average in an Ironman tracking program
14 hours a week okay cool 14 hours a
week
um that's two hours a day okay how can I
position this in my mind to be as simple
as possible okay two hours a day when I
was eight years old going and playing at
the park for two hours that was easy
going and playing basketball for two
hours going swimming at the pool or
riding my bike with my friends for a
couple hours that was easy okay I'm
gonna train like an eight-year-old let
me go play for a couple hours and then I
just have my little push days where it's
like let's play but more like what's
possible
that's it like I did an Iron Man in New
Zealand and I just played like you know
how people wear all like the little like
Iron Man like Triathlon like biking
outfits and all that stuff I wore gym
shorts and a hoodie and I'm just like
dancing and having fun I'm like I'm
gonna play like this is fun like it
doesn't have to be so serious but it's
really just do more a little bit more
you have your little push days have your
little you know it's just that's it
that's my little proprietary way I gotta
make it easy in my mind
because if I make it hard like it's like
in high school let's all go back to high
school uh geometry or algebra two that's
hard yeah I don't want to go to that
class but this position in my brain is
hard
but like gym class that's easy so what
do I want to go to the easy class
so let me stop finding ways for things
to be hard because subconsciously that
inner child is going to be like okay I
know it's hard but I really don't want
to go to the hard thing I really want to
go to the easy thing so I just position
the hardest thing Iron Man marathon is
easy
like today I just left the gym
I did um uh a mile and a half
but to me like I'm a marathon runner
like mile and a half that's what
marathoners do not 26 Miles because
every marathoner starts off the same way
it's like okay cool I'm gonna do my
little mile and a half and I'm gonna do
my little two miles and I'm doing my
little three miles in them like it's
really easy so that's how I try to
position it all the experts that I
listen to say try to ramp It Up by about
like 10 every week or every two weeks a
nice gradual ramp up is how you do it in
a way to be able to maintain it yeah you
don't try to advance your personal
record that's the first day back in the
gym yeah you know what I mean you're
gonna you're gonna hurt yourself so
that's the same [ __ ] see
I can hear you and I'm like yeah yeah
it's like you could apply that [ __ ] to
yours because I I'm man like I said like
y'all didn't want to go and stay I
gained some weight but you know what the
whole time I was like
damn I'm fat as [ __ ] I'm about to get up
on stage all right I guess I'll wear a
black shirt like that's how I felt too
like damn but there's like ways
it's an insecuracy of being able to show
your insecurity is kind of like being
above it in a way absolutely you know
but because I look at it like this it's
um
it's a blessing
so
I'm gonna be a delusional optimist about
any situation I'm in delusional of that
delusional Optimist because if I'm
delusionally optimistic about oh well I
gained 60 pounds well that's a blessing
because when I overcome this
there might be hundreds of millions of
people that are inspired so God had a
plan for me to just be more
inspirational because the people who do
have problems are truly the most
inspirational people on the planet the
perfect people aren't they're
aspirational
not inspirational so like Oprah she was
like sexually abused Oprah was fired
from her job Oprah struggles with her
weight like Oprah like like the list
goes on of all the things she's had
problems with why do you think she's one
of the most inspirational people on the
planet
do you think she ain't got the big butt
and the perfect the bikini picture be
like Oprah what you doing
why are you in a bikini every picture
like no she's real real is such a gift
for anybody else it's really a servitude
like if I have a problem and I own it
and I'm trying to overcome it now I'm
automatically observative see like
I help people every day as a part of my
Foundation or like I help people every
day when I was a manager it was my job
to make two changes a dream come true
Travis Porter young Dolph bankroll fresh
it was my job to make their dream come
true I'm still doing the same thing now
it's this little girl it's my job to
make her but then with my own personal
problems it's my job to take care of me
because that is now a servitude to the
Millions
that if I hold all this stuff into
myself I'm being selfish if I own it and
try
now I can help Millions not just a
couple people in front of me
it's a gift it's a way to articulate
[ __ ] I think you I would have been like
man just get up there and do some [ __ ]
and be inspired yeah so you say it right
you're a motivational speaker man
that was great yeah for damn sure no for
real we have people come on here that we
do the comments my brother helps with
the comments do the first couple
thousand comments for every episode and
the [ __ ] I mean there's people like I'm
trying for this job three weeks later yo
I got this job four weeks later I got it
right yeah we could see this in the
comments we do meet and greet you meet
people and they go yo I'm John 9164 from
YouTube chat what's up how was the baby
like it's different when you start
connecting with people like you like I'm
helping people the way we like to think
like I hope this past the time while
you're in you're stuck at your job
because we used to be stuck at the job
I'm like God I wish I had I wish I was
how many more hours but when you have
somebody to like to talk like a virtual
friend like we're talking about it's
more motivational people look at you I
guarantee you got millions of things
like y'all that's 140 pounds because of
you you know I [ __ ] bought a house
and I got this I left this relationship
because we you said and with him it's
even more substantial because you're
dealing with people who are like
fighting for their lives and I know a
part of your story is having a brain
tumor right and you were able to start
reversing that somehow yeah oh yeah that
was it was especially like a special
moment for me watching that I lost my
dad to cancer he had a horrible battle
for a long time all that lots of people
so it's like seeing that just
it's just even different than what we do
because it's like a different level yeah
you know it's it's even more special
when it takes a lot more because when
just to be willing to get involved in
scenarios like that that are so tragic
over and over that's gotta it takes a
certain kind of individual to be able to
even just do that period let alone to
really like go through with it and make
it your whole transform your whole life
around it now through your foundation
yeah somebody asked me the other day
they said do you get sad like when you
deal with these stories I was like no
I was like I feel it like I feel the
emotion but the room doesn't need
another sad person
I was given I guess the the ability to
see a problem and I feel it but
immediately I'm like how do we fix it if
I start crying and I'm just thinking now
I'm kind of manifesting that something's
wrong if I start feeling that
something's wrong
the only thing I'm thinking about when I
meet that little girl is
okay she's got cancer
she's potentially about to have leukemia
she had cancer in the femur but
immediately I'm not sad for her I'm
thinking about all the possibilities
that can give her something to live for
my brain can only go one direction at a
time like I can't think about two things
at once my brain's not that
sophisticated so it's like I'm either
going to think about how bad it is for
her or I'm gonna think about how good it
is for her and I'm I'm just going to
fill my brain with all the good things
like okay if we do this boom she's gonna
be happy she's gonna have something to
live for she's gonna start healing she's
gonna feel good she's gonna Feel Love
she's gonna feel seen she's got all
these celebrity friends now now she's
like chasing her dream next thing you
know the doctor is thinking oh wow like
this is working even better than we
expected like something is happening
because the body has a lot of power to
heal
if you feel good step one feel good get
an alignment there's this there's this
uh frequency that can exist of healing
Marcus actually told me a story first I
bet I'm gonna start calling stop we're
calling Marcus so first to me is a
genius uh he actually introduced me to
Law of Attraction
um
back before he was ever successful he
showed me the secret but he told me a
story about his father who had cancer
and nothing was working
and then like they had kind of given up
hope a little bit and then Marcus first
went down into the basement and pulled
out his old records Marvin Gaye and all
that stuff brought him upstairs started
playing the music
that started vibrating
that started healing
so that's why my brain won't get sad
my brain goes to the possibilities
immediately
that's just the manifestation too like I
told you don't even think about it don't
even start thinking it's going to be bad
because then you just put that [ __ ] into
the code of coming up next he's talking
about very deliberately how I want to
place my energy and my thoughts that's
what when you really wrap your mind
around the secret that's kind of what it
teaches you to like be responsible for
the way you think like you got to
install your own OS to think a certain
way to perceive things as they come
through the you know your life and
really it's not even like
Hocus Pocus anymore no it's not
frequent frequencies it's literally
quantum physics has explained this and
broken it down very clearly in what way
oh God let me explain it yeah please
because uh I'm more of like I'll give it
a visual thank you this is this is
what's going on this is what's gonna
mess you up
all right guys
can I bring bongs yeah all right
I need four bones
okay we're going to explain quantum
physics with this is the best [ __ ]
thing ever we're just playing Quantum
figures with the bongs love it where's
you should be a teacher
okay so this is what we're gonna do
so we're going to call this a wall and
we got two doors
these are the two doors
and this is a wall this is a wall now in
quantum physics
what they did was they took an atomic
particle a photon
small little particle of light
and they shot it at this wall
boom they just threw it at the wall
and something really weird happened that
spooked everybody out Einstein was like
I don't get this
it was new science that goes completely
against traditional physics
this is an atomic particle they thought
this was a piece of matter
it went through both doors at the same
time if I were to throw this in that
door
it almost went through it went through
that one right
that's how that's how like the material
world is it went through that one if I
shot this and it went through both
you'd be like excuse me did it like
split in half like what happened no this
is what actually ended up happening
this is not a piece of matter
this is what rewrote everything and this
is what proves The Law of Attraction
proven by science this is a wave now
let's say this was a pond right here and
I dropped this in the pond a little wave
goes out
does it go through both yes absolutely a
wave is over there and a wave is over
there now this is the trippy thing
this is what proves The Law of
Attraction so step one everything is a
wave
that means you're not there and I'm not
here
it means if we're in this room we are
literally connected right now because if
you are a wave and everything is away
this is atomic particle everything is
made of atomic particles everything is a
wave so
they took a camera
they said Hold on step two of this
experiment we're putting a camera right
here
we're going to observe this more clearly
they shoot it at the wall
it doesn't go through both
it only went through that one they said
Hold on it acts different when we have a
camera when there's Focus hold on this
is I know this is this is spooky
Einstein was going through the same
thing y'all are going through just like
I don't know about this
so they took the camera they put it over
here
shot it at the wall it went through that
one they're like holy mercy so when we
look somewhere that's where something is
no longer a wave
and it wouldn't they say you know where
uh focus goes energy flows this is where
it comes from
when they focus over here energy goes
here when they focus over here energy go
here no camera goes through both
crazy so where you focus now in quantum
physics
everything is a possibility now when
there's no attention given this wave is
millions of possibilities of locations
superpositions
millions of different places it can be
all of the outcomes are possible
where it's focused
is where it manifests
this is not
this is quantum physics
not to prove how connected we all are
the military did an uh an experiment
where they took them in let's say they
took you
they swabbed your mouth to get your DNA
they put it in a
tea tree dish
and they sent this petri dish
four blocks down the street
put an instrument on it to read the
energy coming off of it
they took you
in this building he had you watch an
emotional film
something that's going to change your
energy they have an instrument on you
reading your energy chart
a petri dish four blocks down
was moving the same as you are this same
you are connected
to that saliva four blocks down
to where its energy chart is changing
the same exact as yours is as you're
watching this emotional film
we are connected to everything you are
not over there and I am not over here
there is a lot of stuff going on in
between us like for example how many
songs and cell phone conversations are
flying past us right now can we see them
exactly can we hear them there's songs
on the radio flying between us there's
no box to to play it but they're there
there's information flying there's
energy one day they will create a camera
they could just simply show us what's
going on in between us like they created
a camera that can show us our x-rays
they created a little camera bloop now I
can see it I can't wait to see what that
camera shows one day with the secret
really like made me think about in terms
of what we're talking about is like a
brainwave is a it's like an audio wave
you can it's a real physical thing like
you're saying that you just can't see
but the brainwave is really going out
and it's impacting on what's coming back
to you whether you realize it or not
just like gravity nobody knows how
gravity works it's still working every
time absolutely So when you say that is
that why twins sense everything so well
you know what I'm saying like even
mothers and their children because me
and my my fiance there'll be times when
I'm like I call it like what's going on
like if I know something what's going on
absolutely like when during the Ted talk
[ __ ] she's in the back she's like
calm down I can feel you from out here
I'm like damn yeah I was freaking out
back you're like yo what's going on are
We next are we done all right study so
that's that blew my [ __ ] I'll tell you
some crazy stuff I'll give you a couple
examples one
um I wanted to manifest being a Nike
athlete like I was 300 pounds I had a
brainstorm I just had a vision I knew I
could do it I would write down every day
I was in a going to be in a commercial
with LeBron James and Serena Williams
every day I write it manifest it feel it
I wasn't the biggest Nike commercial of
all time with LeBron James Serena
Williams and I won an Emmy forward and
it was the Colin Kaepernick commercial
it's the biggest Nike commercial of all
time stock price went up nine billion
dollars and I wanted Emmy for it and it
was named after me the [ __ ] yes
I miss your whole damn speech man damn
so wait you want to Emmy for the
commercial the commercial we watched the
the Colin Kaepernick commercial no this
is all the colors that was my fan made
Nike commercial which was a whole nother
manifestation because I needed a
filmmaker for that so I was writing down
because to make a Nike commercial Nike
gray Nike commercial like the one you
saw your commercial level production
like that's like sixty hundred thousand
dollars because you got to make the
original music Hans Zimmer type music
the anamorphic lenses the lighting the
sound design all that stuff and I
manifested one person
and everybody told me I was crazy you're
not going to find somebody who can do
that for cheap
guy walked in my front door
I wrote in my notebook today is the day
I find
the videographer is going to do this for
me he walked in my front door we made
that commercial with six hundred dollars
damn Nike saw it flew me to New York I
mean flew me to Portland Oregon Eugene
Oregon not Eugene Beaverton OR Beaverton
yes and then
they changed the entire direction of
their company but I manifested like
working with Oprah boom next day a man
of I need an author for my book so I
just tell people my dreams what I'm
looking for next day this guy runs into
my friend at the office and he says man
what are you working on he said oh I'm
working with this guy named Charlie he
saw it he said
wow does he want to write a book with me
this is a 24 hours later New York Times
bestselling author so it's like these
manifestations they happen it's not
woohoo it's literally when you're tapped
in
and you're like this delusional Optimist
and you're feeling so good you're
feeling so possible when you get away
from a physical state and get more into
an energy state
now you connect with everything it's
almost like you get off the elevator you
know the cell phone on the elevator like
we'll call the elevator like
negativity uh um like this like gravity
of Life the elevators of gravity of life
you can't truly connect you walk off the
elevator perfect reception so it's like
if there's anything negative in my life
or anything that's holding me back from
feeling good like I got to get off this
elevator once I get off the elevator get
all the negative people away from me
if I feel good now all of a sudden I got
full reception if I have full reception
now I can truly connect to everything
that I want to manifest even as
information flowing to me ideas are
flowing downloads they call it downloads
you ever wonder why I like our artist
you know has like a chapter of their
life where they're like channeling
greatness I guarantee you fetty WAP
wrote them three songs within the same
month you know you know I guarantee you
he was channeling something you know
some people know how to stay in the
channel
sometimes
people when they struggle they channel
so good
but then once they get success it puts
them in the elevator and then they don't
know how to connect anymore because now
they got all these things blocking their
frequency but it's like if you can stay
grounded and channel now information can
flow back you send information out it
comes back you see what I'm saying great
analogy I got to be honest perfect way
to put it I always say the
I'm not going to say but there's certain
negative people in your life I realize
like I have to get away from or not get
away from you I have to stiff arm you
slightly keep you at a distance
so I can keep this negativity like I
said it's like a [ __ ] I'm hot there's
a heater right there it's not killing me
but it's not [ __ ] helping me that's
right away from it that's right so I can
just cool down a little bit that's how
I've been feeling lately and like
everything's been work I mean I'm not
gonna say but everything's been [ __ ]
well oil machine just doing this and
when I did that like yo we can
I deal with this thing in my life when I
can deal with it like right now I can't
yeah decided you just need to start
focusing on this so I can feel blind
when I wake up so I can go knock [ __ ]
out that's right do you uh so you're
doing the computer and your whole desk
is messy can you I can't think like I
feel like my [ __ ] has to be annoyed I
have to be good to be ready to go that's
right that I can get my best [ __ ] out
because I'm not thinking of yeah my
brain's not preoccupied the tough talk
really taught us about mental bandwidth
and how much we can actually oh man it
did do yeah within a amount of time in
terms of cranking out the production on
our three channels writing the talk
memorizing the talk and getting ready to
go and actually deliver it on top of
moving sets this week uh yeah yeah
so he's talking about you know the day
after the Ted Talk having a hundred
missed text messages
all this drama coming out I'm just
bouncing off him because just that much
in the zone that's really how it was
it's true like a lot of [ __ ] with my
family this weekend hey I'll [ __ ]
talk to you someday I'll talk to you
Saturday I need I can't I realized that
there is a mental bandwidth you think
you could do everything you can't you
have to see I gotta find a videographer
because I'm not a videographer but I
gotta find some of the same work ethic
as me that I can say green light you're
the guy same thing like Marty Mike I
found Marty we just started doing this
because we found somebody like oh I
bounce off you bounce off me there's
nothing bad here let's keep going yeah
so when you find those people and you're
that guy you're that guy for everyone
else you know what I'm saying so it's
cool to see this we've never had a guest
that's
can articulate what the [ __ ] they're
trying to say in a way that every single
camera every person can be oh you know I
kind of feels you're communicating the
overall message of this podcast much
more intelligent thank you thank you
thank you for saying it good
hey what's up guys taking a moment to
talk about one of our sponsors and this
is ship station right here push trees we
have been using shipstation actively for
over half a decade and from personal
experience from a small business owner
the number one reason on Earth that
people leave abandoned carts are
shipping costs too high of shipping
costs they see the rate and go nope not
buying it in the world of e-commerce the
most prevalent thing is competition and
to stay one step ahead of the
competition having lower shipping costs
I'm telling you from me to you ship
station can help you keep your customers
happy lower shipping costs keep things
very organized ship station makes it
easy in one interface for you it's easy
to set up and the trial is free if
you're a small business owner there is
no reason for you not to try it out from
me to you it's worth it if you use
Amazon
Etsy eBay any of those can be integrated
with shipstation automated shipping
tasks print shipment labels all the
information everything you need that's
sending out the tracking shipstation can
do every single thing for you all of
these things perfectly and iterate
together this is for the small business
owner go to shipstation.com use our code
dope as usual and that's 60 days for
free over a hundred thirty thousand
people small business owners have tried
ship station ninety eight percent of the
people that use it stay forever and like
I said I've been using shipstation for
over half a decade get your 60-day free
trial right now by going to
shipstation.com forward slash dope as
usual so thank you so much to ship
station for sponsoring the show back to
the episode
now one person that is I know a lot of
our fans was a you know really listened
to and was a huge fan of that you worked
with was young at all yeah and that you
know
is there any stories or anything that we
might not know about him that we should
know about man I missed off god dog
man I was a mega fan of Dolph so I was
managing two chains at the time and um
people don't know this but two changes
first paid feature ever
was young Dolph young dog young Dolph
was in the streets and he was a big fan
of tit
but getting to change his career off the
ground wasn't the easiest he had been
around for so long already right people
don't realize that he had like a 20-year
career before he was like 38 39 before
he really started popping like 34. 34.
oh okay yeah so I was like 21 when I
started managing uh tit
um but doff I mean I loved off so much
because in a time where rappers had
become
uh uh we'll call them like more like
drug addicts than drug dealers you know
things go in waves it's it's normal like
you know
um when I was growing up gzti Gucci man
this is where I would like drug dealers
or I call them just entrepreneurs at the
end of the day doing the drugs wasn't
cool yeah it's just like you know like
what are you doing like if you're high
you're not gonna be focused on running
your business operation
so I craved that still but I always was
looking for what was next in hip-hop and
like I always had a gift of um seeing
around the corner so like when I came
into the game I came in with Soulja Boy
so it's like we ushered in the the viral
era of hip-hop so then you had this
extreme like viral Dance Movement and I
said okay
um what's next it's gonna be this kind
of like singing
dance music I mean singing kind of like
energy so like before this is before
future I kind of saw it and Travis
Porter they were doing that it was a a
guy in the group called quiz and he had
this almost singing voice but like not
singing it's normal today
um but you know uh with Travis Porter it
was like okay that started popping off
and the girls really liked him but then
I was like okay what's next I was like
right now it's kind of girl dance Twerk
Music what's next it's gonna be the
streets it's gonna go from this like
young to like oh the pendulum always
swings so in business you always gotta
look for the pendulum
it's like usually
culturally uh you gotta break a rule to
be next
so like when you have
um fashion for example
we went from really baggy clothes to
like well what's going to be next really
skinny clothes because people want
identity
that's just um I call it the little
brother theory in business and if
anybody's watching this who who's
thinking about business you actually
have an extreme advantage
if you're not good at something
so like
I'll give you an example
if you're really bad at something I
think you have
a better chance of making it than
somebody who is extremely talented
because
let's say at the time Future's popping
right
Lil yachty comes around so like all of
us your big brother your little brother
you like future
little brother when he's little he
really wants to be like his big brother
so he's gonna like anything you like but
then once he gets to a certain age he
wants to start having his own identity
so he's going to secretly start liking
the things that are the opposite of what
you like so he's going to start liking
Playboy cardi like and then you're like
man what is this [ __ ] he ain't even
saying nothing
they were like oh that's not real
hip-hop like but that gives them an
identity so it's like first time I heard
Playboy cardi I'm like
I don't know what this is but then I'm
seeing this like cult like fan base
and I'm like holy [ __ ]
we're like if you try to be just like
future you might end up like designer I
didn't want to say it or exactly or if
you're traditionally not good by the
scheme of things you you're going to
represent an entire generation in their
identity by not being good people didn't
think uh uh Soulja Boy was any good you
know even when future came out they call
this Mumble round the older folks are
like nah this ain't good like uh Migos
oh this ain't good but you representing
an entire younger brother generation so
if you're technically not good I think
you have an advantage
it's just you can't be too smart about
how you're going about it and compare
yourself you got to understand them you
know like if if you don't have the good
microphone
or the good producer you still have an
advantage because if you go listen to
xxx's First music sound like
but that represents the little brother
Theory the little brother now likes that
so the older brother's like man man I
don't know what that is
that's exactly how it works this I heard
100 herb Gotti breakdown this was his
exact thought when putting out DMX he
was like we had puffy in the shiny shoes
we had Jay-Z over here in the Rolls
Royce with the suit on DMX was the have
not he came through his get at me dog I
had all the lights flashing I'm [ __ ]
up your eyes we're not clean we're not
cute we're the [ __ ] streets that was
the same [ __ ] he was that next
Generation rip the the contrast and he
was his own Mega Superstar when he would
have looked at him like look this
[ __ ] kid out
living on the [ __ ] top of this roof
out here this dog when we had the puffy
era hip hop but his super stardom was
just as big and then you can say the
same thing for Kanye because Kanye
served
um I mean they thought he was gay but it
served like if you look at the the
scheme of like um how things go it's
like okay things have traditionally
gotten a little bit softer and softer
and softer and softer right Kanye was at
the right place the right time and he
just owned it but that was the little
brother thing because Big Brother's like
man we from the streets little brother's
like I got my Polo backpack
a little choir on the song Little you
know music you know and it's just like
that's a gift to be at that point where
you can shift culture and you shift
Culture by breaking rules so going all
the way back
I felt young Dolph and in the time of
hip-hop we needed a drug dealer we need
an entrepreneurial rapper again
and I was like he's the one like he's my
favorite like I get motivated by him and
end off with such a businessman like I
just like would drive to Memphis every
day and just like meet with them and be
like man I really want to manage you and
he was like man I don't sound to nobody
I was like I get it but I really got a
vision for you and I just started
putting points on the board and I didn't
ask for permission to be great I just
wanted to show I could bring value
and
I mean it took off I remember
the first record I started pushing was
uh
If You Ain't Talking Money I Don't Wanna
talk
and then we found preach and it's the
first time I ever heard on the way to
San Francisco drive to to LA and I heard
him
what the [ __ ] is this
yeah that's the first song I ever heard
Dolph taught me a lot about value too
because I was I was I ran a very like
successful management company but I was
always like get it out the mud type
mindset like look like off do this show
for 1500 it's a good opportunity we got
to be moving we gotta he's like I'm not
doing nothing for less than 2 20 000.
I'm like Jim that's not how it works
like we got to be active yeah he's like
I'm worth 20.
excuse me the spark in the water he's
like I'm worth 20 000. and I'm like
all right
let me ask for twenty thousand and they
said yes hmm they sing I know tall skin
60 80 000 to book a nightclub and I'm
like wow like he taught me like
you can still get to the same place even
if you take different streets it's like
sometimes you got to know your worth
and I feel them I learned a lot that I
applied today because there's brands
that come and try to do deals with me
for five hundred thousand seven hundred
fifty thousand dollars I send them away
it's like no I know my value it's like
I'm not doing a promo code keep your 750
000 yeah I'm not doing that because
Hasbro's coming
right you know yeah yeah you know the
Hillsboro story I read a little bit
about it yeah the Hasbro story was crazy
toys yeah it was a crazy it was actually
a manifestation story I never tell this
you have a Hasbro toy no bro you got a
little you better I had a truck I had
the diesel so so in the pandemic I'm
touring Across America getting the
foundation off the ground but I'm just
helping people they told us all to go in
the house and I went outside like I'm
like I'm I'm going outside people need
help so it got to about seven months
into the tour and the foundation ran out
of money I was selling my houses
given basically giving all my money away
because I believed in this vision for
what I'm trying to build I put in 600
000 of my own dollars into my Foundation
I'm not that rich you know but I have
enough to go try to build something
um
and then we had we had the foundation
ran out of money money my manager quit
right when the money ran out it was like
those dark times and then I was like
look I'm gonna stop the tour for three
weeks I'm gonna go set up shop in
Atlantic City I was in New York when my
manager quit so I was like let me go
down to Atlantic City get a little
Airbnb and just like start fundraising
and part of my fundraising strategy is
not just making phone calls part of my
fundraising strategy is also
manifestation there's a little church
down the way that had a labyrinth it's
like a little maze type thing where you
kind of like pray and manifest in it
like you walk in it and it's just a cool
thing called Labyrinth
um and then I'll go out to the beach and
I'll just like manifest and like close
my eyes and what transpired was
I manifested I said I see a company
donating 500 000 dollars
to our mission I saw it now I wasn't
making any phone calls to companies I
was just calling Rich individuals for
donations
um but then I got a phone call
from this lady named Jen at Hasbro
and I was like holy Mercy is this it is
this it cause all my boys know like I'm
like no I've been manifesting this
everybody knows there's like this
Wizardry that is possible when I write
stuff down so everybody's like excited
so I said I said this might be it so I
get on the zoom call with Hasbro and
we're like excited we're like I'm like
so what y'all thinking you're like we
really love what y'all do
we want to donate
fifty thousand dollars to y'all still
I'm look no super grateful super great
most but then I looked at my boys and I
was like damn
it wasn't the one because I wrote down
500 000. yeah I was like okay it's gonna
happen though it's gonna happen the next
day Hasbro calls back and they said we
were doing this big influencer campaign
that we just would rather y'all do this
instead of like all these other
influencers just doing random dances or
something we want to increase the budget
to 150 000. I was like really I was like
still not the 500 but that's great like
but I'm like this is a blessing like
it's working
and then the next day Jen calls me
she said word has gotten out in the
company about what y'all do and it got
up to the boss and the boss said he
wants to take the whole entire Christmas
Market and budget
450
000 dollars
and what we did over the next three
weeks was we built toy stores in the
mall where like you kids underprivileged
kids can compay when Monopoly money get
as many toys as they want we gave away
houses we gave away cars we gave away
puppies we gave away and it was the
craziest 30 days that what we did with
Hasbro but it's like I knew it was gonna
happen it wasn't the 500 000 it was 450
we ended up raising 750 000 in three
weeks wow but see it wasn't just a
business strategy it was also an energy
strategy
you see what I'm saying 100 like I
believe delusionally it was gonna happen
and then when we only got the 50 000.
I was a little down it's human
but then look what happened a couple
days later like that's that's that's a
real story
it's crazy it's [ __ ] insane bro all
those toys people grew up with bro you
can get on when you really start
deliberately moving like this over the
years you gain momentum like that I feel
like and to the point where it's like I
did this and I can point to it and look
at this [ __ ] like yeah yeah on that Epic
Level yeah it really worked because I
mean I know you probably haven't seen
the show this is what we preach every
[ __ ] week if it's not sometimes you
don't have a guest and it's just me and
him going for two and a half hours
talking about you know life and this and
I feel like
you've articulated a way that people
could come home with something instead
of like you know I like that show they
motivate me now it's like oh I can use
steps on why I'm motivated yeah I feel
like you kind of put it into a sense
that we could take home you're gonna be
like manifestation for dummies for me
because I understood everything like
see I still particularly how I feel
about the way you said it I'm trying I'm
trying par our talk was called
definition of a hustler because as you
know the theme of the evening was how to
start from scratch with nothing that's
right and we found the hustlers the
epitome of that somebody that can go
outside with nothing and come back from
something yeah and our real advice to
people was
find what you're good at find what you
love and find what adds value to other
people and where those three overlap is
where your
Finish Line is where your Marathon
begins yeah is there anything that you
tell people when they're like I don't
know what path I want I have all this
energy I just don't know what's for me
absolutely
um
so
so like every every part of your journey
is just practice so the first thing is
like
I think it's very dangerous
um to always be looking
out into this like perfect place when I
just tell you this when I was in high
school I was pretty popular
but I was uh in a tough situation
because I wanted to be a part of the
basketball team but I was too I wasn't
good enough to be on the high school
team
so I go to the coach and be like what
can I do he said there's only one spot
it's the manager it's a water boy gotta
sweep the floor gotta do these things
usually popular kids won't do of course
and I'm like I'll do it
I'm gonna do it with pride
and it's like okay is that my dream job
no but it's practice I must sweep that
floor at half time in front of everybody
I'm handing that water to the player
just like everybody
and just like okay I'm gonna do that
great
then I'm a cameraman for rappers
cameraman and Hip-Hop is usually
disrespected they don't even call you
your name they just be like cameraman
shoot this cameraman why the camera not
on but it's like how can I do that the
same way as a water boy so okay this is
practice if I can be great at this thing
that's not my dream job
I can I can learn everything the
cameraman's in every room cameraman can
soak up what's happening in this meeting
cameraman can know these radio DJs
cameraman can know how managers think
cameraman can know everything
so it's like I'm gonna this ain't my
dream job but that's okay I'm gonna do
it with Excellence it's practice and
then when I became a manager
was that my dream job still no
because it's like still like just like
kind of you get you know it's a tough
thing to do I'm not going to talk [ __ ]
about it because it's a blessing but
it's no different than the water boy or
the cameraman it's like kind of like
this just servitude job
but it's tough you get yelled at and all
sorts of stuff but I'm gonna do it with
excellence and then when I left that
then I'm like okay now I'm in my dream
job but I'm living multiple lives
getting to it I used to sell vacuum
cleaners I used to have clothing lines
like all sorts of stuff but do it with
excellence and climb a ladder like when
you do something it doesn't have to be
the whole book it could just be a
chapter but how could that chapter be
the best chapter because if the chapter
ain't good people gonna tune out of the
book I need the whole book to be good so
this chapter I'm gonna do Excellence
this chapter I'm gonna do Excellence
this chapter and that's really hustling
because it's like you don't have to
worry about where you're at when you
know where you're going exactly I can be
fine right here in this shitty situation
because I know where I'm going but let
me do this better than anybody while I'm
here while this is right this is exactly
the [ __ ] I swear to God everything he's
saying is exactly what we say every week
it's [ __ ] great to hear from another
perspective see it working because
you're doing [ __ ] on a global level and
you're following the same steps as the
dude that works at McDonald's and I
worked at McDonald's I was like I
[ __ ] hate doing this meat but watch
my [ __ ] be the best [ __ ] burgers on
the shift my shit's clean look like
there's just take pride in everything
you do and then the things that you love
I mean it becomes second nature of like
no it's a given that I'm gonna crush it
what the [ __ ] you're talking about I'm
gonna knock it out yeah because it
becomes a confidence more than an
arrogance it's not like arrogance like
I'm confident in my in my brain
yeah it's a confidence within yourself
that you're you're working towards
something that you might not even know
what it is that's what we realize too
like podcasting didn't exist when you
said I was on some mixtape rapper [ __ ]
he was selling packs of weed like you
may not have known that this life you're
living now was even what you wanted to
do way back when you started in the
record business that probably wasn't
even a thing but as you kind of it's
like in the secret Jack Canfield said
one of our favorite Expressions you can
drive across the country in the dark
with your headlights on just seeing the
15 feet in front of you and just working
with what's there and then eventually
you're like oh [ __ ] I didn't even know
what could be this good I'm here yep
absolutely yeah a living example of it
thank you question how did you grow up
where did you grow how did you grow up
you have both parents you guys grow up
with money you guys grow up struggling
this is another like a building block I
like to ask people like how was it
growing up Atlanta Georgia man
um I grew up I grew up in Atlanta my dad
was a blues musician my mom was a vacuum
cleaner sales woman that's why you sold
vacuums my grandfather wasn't me too and
Charlie it's my dad the blues musician
yeah your dad's a blues musician too
yeah that's crazy they literally what I
did so yeah man like I I
I grew up
very anti-social though
in which I've always think was a gift I
think it's the greatest gift uh that I
had as a child because like I was even
though I was kind of popular I was
scared to go in environments that I
couldn't control like I never go to a
house party even a football game on a
Friday night High School football game
was like nervous to me like I didn't
know how to do that so I look at that as
such a blessing because
it made me
uh overcompensate so I needed people to
come into my world because I early on
identified I don't enjoy going into
theirs so if I start businesses people
can come into my world because I want to
interact with people Sports it was great
because it's like the basketball team
it's my world
but then when I couldn't do Sports well
what am I going to do I buried my dream
of Athletics
I always wanted to be an athlete so then
I buried that dream and I became a
businessman that gave me a way to
interact and then I got good at it but
um growing up I'll say
uh a combo of of lower class and middle
class
um my dad my dad was just like a
carpenter mechanic um
my mom obviously my parents never made
more than thirty thousand dollars a year
combined
um but
they were smart they were smart with
their money they saved every penny so
like my dad he would save the money so
much that like in the winter time and it
go it gets cold in Atlanta like they'll
get down to like zero degrees my dad
wouldn't turn the heat on to save money
and he would use the fireplace
and this is like pops like cut the heat
on man he's like now we're saving we're
saving we're saving I'm like all right I
get it
I didn't understand until later it was
important lessons because my dad would
save every penny they would make and
then they would buy like a low rental
property
and then in the neighborhood they own
five little like rental properties in
the house and when we were growing up we
grew up in a part of Atlanta like where
it was kind of like a white trash
Community but like transitioning out
like kind of being like houses being
torn down and building new houses so my
parents were in the right place at the
right time they were buying these little
houses and then the house we grew up in
it was built in like 1910 super old
house
but then when my parents got divorced
the judge made them sell everything
the house I grew up in my parents bought
for like forty thousand
they sold it for 1.1
and that's one house how did the value
go up so [ __ ] how much time ago how
much time had passed probably like 20
years wow so they got divorced when I
was 18. so I graduated high school
moved in with my mom put a studio in my
mom's basement we moved basically like a
down the street put a studio in my mom's
basement that's when my hip-hop career
started and uh like a lot of Atlanta
hip-hop culture was in my mom's basement
and then you know I ended up you know
Soldier Boy's cameraman and then got
fired and then ended up discovering this
girl group got him a record deal they
left me for Sierra's manager I got fired
again
and then I discovered Travis Porter and
I was like I'm gonna treat this like a
business not so much like music music
you always think about a record deal
business
you think about
just like the system of like if I do
this this much revenue will come in not
even looking to Gatekeepers a business
if you have a coffee shop you're not
looking in a gatekeeper even YouTube
you're not even look you're like it's a
business if I do this content boom if I
get this boom so I started treating
music like a business
and I would pass out CDs every night and
I'll do like eight hours of Myspace
comments every day
like run into play like I'm just like
boom it's a carpal tunnel yeah I got it
too from all the years of doing [ __ ]
yeah but I'm running that play
Travis Porter's career takes off and I
discovered titty boy two chains and then
bankroll fresh rip bankroll R.I.P Dolph
like I was really in it like in Atlanta
it was um
it was it was it was pretty calm for the
first you need to hit that
um
but like you know it we
in Atlanta it was it was such a blessing
I loved it I loved music and I miss it
so much
I'm gonna go back in a different way not
as like a manager but I want to give
back
I feel I feel such a a passion for
teaching young artists how powerful they
are
and that it's always an outward look
like an artist always feels like oh I
need a manager I just always like I need
a record label I just always like
you know I need these things in order to
have a tour or to get on a radio or it's
like no like if you only understood your
power
you have
the ability to upload a song
and the song is way more viral than a
YouTube video could ever be a song it's
more powerful than a movie or a book a
song it's the only thing on this planet
that can get billions
of streams we'll do a TED Talk it might
max out at 10 million a song can have
billions and billions there's just
nothing like it it's literally Universal
universal language
so I wish artists knew their passion so
when I go back to music I'm going to go
back on a mission
to just like change as many lives as
possible because I want people to
experience that dream I love that man
I've only had one idea with my fiance
it's like I want to get to a point where
I can go back my hometown like buy an
apartment complex yeah anybody going to
school or actively trying to do Music
Arts filming anything could live for
free while they're doing their thing
that's big I'd be sick right like a
little of the rent taken off of here
it's a thousand dollars a person like
bro it's perfect like you can change
someone's life for a thousand dollars
they only stay for four months they're
gone yeah you know I mean like they're
gone they left now we got a new for it
because I always feel like they're the
young us is out there the young us needs
to see
the results of like dude I was you I
worked at McDonald's I work multiple
jobs I worked here I got [ __ ] it I hated
it but I knew one day like it's just the
it's just my path I know this will be
I'll be thinking about this later like
when I stop selling like
I got no money no more but it'll be
worth it one day it took 10 years but I
could see that one day I know I'll be
sitting there stoked I'm on the stage
doing I I see these things like
like the next week's episode check out
wait for next week's episode you'll see
this and that's how I feel more kind of
like the you were saying the
visualization I just see it more of like
uh screenshots of
I think that's going to happen I don't
know the path to get there or how I'm
going to get there but it always [ __ ]
works out once you
necessarily I'll do the Ted Talk speech
again it always works out once you start
putting in your
positive effort and like we talked about
earlier like you just gotta there's only
so much bandwidth you could do there's
only so much negativity that can be
around you before it starts going inside
of your path and like blinding you a
little yes sir so there's a lot of
people like we do the comments there's a
lot of people out there like you know my
family this I'm sure you have family
that you're like you know what I need to
stay away from just a little bit so I
can start doing my thing we all have it
it's no not all perfect even [ __ ]
rich and ball like
my dad's not perfect I still have to
deal with that [ __ ] so it's like there's
stuff you have to do all the time yeah
and I feel like the way you can thank
you for coming on the show too of course
the way you articulate everything the
way you said everything I feel like
these comments are gonna be different
than any comments we've done I feel like
this is what was needed right now it's a
new year people need to start looking
forward to something something they can
actually look forward to even if it's
not tangible or materialized yet it's
there I'll tell you one of my goals
because I I
I have a I have a really big passion of
starting over
I like proving what's possible
um and Reinventing constantly and
there's this um
shift I'm making right now in my entire
organization because you know we got
lots of light Tick Tock followers we got
like seven million on your Dream
Foundation thing just mine oh it's yours
I'll take that okay okay
um and then you know like a million on
Instagram but I'm like
I came into the game doing YouTube like
me and Soulja Boy invented YouTube like
we didn't call it a vlog
it wasn't named yet but we're the first
vloggers like
YouTube is so powerful and I told my
team the other day I said I'm making a
shift I'm going completely left
and I said it's going to be really
difficult because it's unlike any other
platform YouTube is like a business and
a business I look at I look at YouTube
as like the NBA where like Tick Tock and
Instagram are like uh Streetball not
even minor links it's street ball you
can have all the popularity in the world
and you might have a couple Skip to My
lose or like hot sauces but like talk
about anyone often on this show bro
but then in the NBA it's like
there's only a few there
who really
all successfully rich and you know like
there's no there's no books on YouTube
who are successful there's plenty of you
know so I said listen we're going to
take an entire shift and we're going to
go all in on YouTube
and I'm applying all these same things
and I'm like okay I told my team we're
uploading every day every day every day
like we got a lot of backloaded content
so it's a little bit easier but I said
goal number one we're gonna average
um
10 000 views a day so then
it took us about five weeks to get to
about ten thousand views a day just like
our Baseline View and then it took five
days
to get to 20 000 views a day
and I said see this is what obsession is
I'm like studying the analytic I'm like
I got a few employees and they're seeing
how obsessed I get at the beginning of
starting a business all about that
Obsession and I'm like diving in I know
every little retention rate for every
video and I know this and that and I
told my team I was like you got to be
that obsessed like we're starting a
business here this ain't YouTube you
hear YouTube no this is a business and
there's going to be something that
cracks this thing wide open and we're
not going to know exactly when or where
but if we're that consistency and so
we're on a mission right now to be by
the end of January a hundred thousand a
day a day good [ __ ] and then by uh like
April a million a day like I'm not
messing around with it but I want to
actually learn from you because I
haven't done YouTube since 2007. oh damn
that's a long time bro we're talking
about Crank That Soldier that's all the
first time I ever heard that I was
buying mushrooms in front of my high
school going to buy oranges who's
soldier boy I swear to God that was I
was 17 years old the first time I heard
that song I remember it too yeah so [ __ ]
you guys are doing YouTube and I was not
even here I didn't have a smartphone yet
yeah the iPhone came out when we were on
tour together oh [ __ ] Soulja Boy really
was the first one with the iPhone the
cool way Samsung
oh hell no I had a brick I had it on my
vision board
a black bear on your vision board a
sidekick what advice would you have for
me because I'm a student I'm not an
expert I'm always a student what advice
do you have for me to get to that
million views a day for YouTube right
now exactly what the [ __ ] you're doing
on your other platforms this extend it
longer
people want to see something that
you can you can capture the attention of
a five-year-old to 85 year old and
they'll all have the same emotion of
happiness and like wow oh my God is
there more see the things you do aren't
about you they're you're there as the
Bob Barker yeah you're like I'm moving
this along and you guys are the audience
yeah and then oh the special showcase
winner is the person we're [ __ ]
helping today yeah that's how I feel
like you're like when you think of shows
like [ __ ] Bob Barker when you think
of like people giving back Oh you mean
Charlie that's how I think you are going
to be on the whole YouTube platform okay
and the only advice I have is your
advice you're doing better than I am
you're uploading every [ __ ] day
you're gonna crush it man people want
you can have your favorite all right
your favorite rapper ever you put the
song you're like damn I might Loop that
[ __ ] back that's right I'm putting the
CD back on yeah you know let's play it
again and three months ago
damn what mine is that what I said and I
can listen to that [ __ ] twice yeah
people do that with videos go oh I got
bored I um I didn't upload uh it's been
a week oh you know what I got busy on
Thursday and he's up was a Thursday I'll
catch it next week and that next week
never happens yeah so what it is is to
upload every day you're catching people
that are at work on Monday but they're
not on Tuesday and then I work on
Wednesday but they don't work there so
you see what you're gonna do is gonna
we treat exactly like a business like
how can I well I just started getting
paid on my channel I never got paid
before until [ __ ] five weeks ago
right 2.5 billion watch time yeah no I
don't get paid because I do weed [ __ ] so
I'll get money but I did get a check the
other day for like 1800 bucks I was like
[ __ ] but the podcast should get paid
podcast we do we do they [ __ ] podcast
is Boomer yeah he's like yes it's doing
good it's doing good no big booming yes
but for yours what you're already doing
man is it I wouldn't upload under eight
minutes okay or if that's my only advice
to you give people 10 to 12 minutes if
you don't want to go too long other than
that [ __ ] give you full length my new
story time coming that's an hour and a
half coming out this week who's somebody
who's young that's breaking the rules
because I always want to study what's
next as well I know you know the space
but like
everything like I remember like Vlogs
were a thing and then the people did
like the concept videos started winning
and Vlogs fell out
but what what's a rule that can break
because sometimes things do come back
around just like people with baggy pants
right now they're cool where it's you
it's you it's what you're gonna do okay
you're gonna be the new thing that
breaks the rule of things okay that's
how I see it because what you're doing
on Tick Tock what you're doing on your
other platforms
people try to do that as their whole
image when it's just what you want to be
[ __ ] doing to help and by the way
it's recorded by the way it's recorded
well it's not just like okay um we need
30 000 views find someone that's sick
no it's more like yo we found someone
said we filmed it damn we got 30 million
views that's what your shit's gonna be
it's going to be more like
I could see it by June like CNN doing a
piece like look at this YouTuber out
here giving back to an entire school
like that's how I see it happening don't
go under to eight minutes that's all
like for me to you amen under 10 minutes
premiere of the video and be in there oh
they're laughing not premieres anymore
when he was back then yeah Premiere is a
big tool thank you Premiere so Premiere
instead of live I'm gonna tell you what
I'm really going to do I'm gonna throw a
physical Premiere as well every every
Big video we do yeah big ones well we
got a Dream Factory but yes oh yeah
that's right up but yeah so so this
Saturday our first premiere because it
was actually a video we made about the
whole like trying to pull off the Mr
Beast thing so we did it I met the
little girl and then Incorporated the
Ted Talk and then okay how do we get Mr
Beast and then it actually happened and
then boom so that's gonna be like our
first like big YouTube Premiere where I
like promote it a lot of videos I just
upload but then the big promotion this
is what Premiere is on YouTube now we do
it every single video we've not missed a
[ __ ] Premiere in five years okay you
press public private schedule yeah press
schedule say our show comes out our show
is coming out today every Monday at
three o'clock but things with Premiere
yeah it has a live chat on the side and
we all watch it for the first time
together commenting back together
talking to people there's thousands of
people in there chatting whoa that part
was [ __ ] nuts and I responded to them
oh you know what actually me Marty did
this this and this and we're in there
though every [ __ ] video every Monday
for no matter it's four hour video one
hour video where they're typing the
whole every Monday every Thursday from
other channel it's just imagine watching
the new Adam Sandler movie and he's in
the chat with you like go get ready for
this next part guys man you're gonna
love it that's like the crazy thing we
go live 15 minutes before all right get
ready this is what we're doing today's
guest blah blah go and then [ __ ] starts
I gotta pee really bad
all right cool I'm enjoying this so much
by the way sorry
this is a great [ __ ] episode man
now but for real thank you this has been
just the mo the unexpectedly
motivational I expect it to be motivated
well I mean
I knew what we're getting into yeah but
when you really break things down I feel
like the audience is really gonna my
little brother just text me I love this
episode he's [ __ ] right here yeah
it's a good one man I just
I want I would I've never met no one
like you man I gotta be honest
I never met nobody so uh optimistic and
I love it last night I was trying to
tell my friend Ralph
I've met people like no it's not it's
not me not for me not in this life I'm
like bro you have no idea how poor I've
been in like [ __ ] ready to break down
and like move back I can't do it not
gonna work but I feel like yo any of
your obstacles you could have stopped
have you done
you could have been done but there's a
reason why you're still here is because
you know I feel like a lot of people
don't realize your brain is so much more
powerful than it is you see that [ __ ]
it's because it's happening it's just
not here yet you're just looking to the
preview of like next week's episode of
quantum physics
and now that you explained it and it
makes perfect sense all the
possibilities are already defined it's
literally
the quantum possibilities there's
millions of paths that at the Finish
Line are already determined there's some
Butterfly Effect [ __ ] when you put that
camera somewhere that's where it goes
it literally is where the energy goes
every time but it's already done time
just hasn't caught up yet
no it really is I think about it all the
time what if I didn't do that thing I
would have been dead I would forward
kill like I always think these little
things like I learned that from here and
it helped me out 30 years later I just
didn't know
I just people watch this every week so I
hope you guys take away from this
episode what I'm trying to take away
I've never left the show yeah that's
what I was trying to do good [ __ ] good
[ __ ] I feel better like I I got Gears
turning in my head exactly different
than usual
what are we dreaming right now let's
come on let's manifest
um the only dream I have is like and
years are like coming up now it doesn't
even matter with something big so I just
want to take over that Jimmy Jimmy
Kimmel spot you actually one day you
actually have the personality for that
one day I'm gonna be like so tonight
guys president
like hey America Let Me Entertain You
guys for an hour every night that's what
I want to do the Johnny Carson
eventually you have that gift thank you
that's not even it doesn't even seem
like it's gonna be hard to be honest
that's right because you'll probably
inspire people more than who was before
you
I hope so you're as entertaining but you
also have this like depth thanks bro
appreciate it and you got the spice you
know the world you come from people need
human yeah really bad and like you come
from a world that's like culturally
relevant and that's where things are
going anyways so I think that's probably
easier than you yes a lot of that hard
work is done yeah it's the same thing
so Marty what's you yeah well I I'm
unique because I just realized that like
I call it my Finish Line I just hit my
first Finish Line last year through this
podcast which was you know I mean moving
out here I've been out here almost 10
years now buying my first house
renovating the house getting all my [ __ ]
together is just a human by the time I
was 35. so that was that was it we're
still on the back end of renovate in the
house right now and to get the podcast
up to the point that it could be one of
the biggest podcasts in the world so I
took I had a roster of like 10 big
Comedians and businesses and should I
work with over the past two years I
started working with him we funneled it
down to where it's basically just now me
and him yeah so now like we're really
realizing a lot of the Big Dreams from
the vision board moving into the new
studio season three ratcheting this up
to the point that Financial Freedom is
really like the next goal of like
it's you know you hit a couple of those
milestones and now it's like [ __ ] I can
do it it's evident I have proof now it's
I'm not just a dreamer like I was like
you people thought I was [ __ ] crazy
though because I was from Buffalo like
deep in some hip-hop Eight Mile [ __ ] and
I started talking all the [ __ ] after I
saw the secret they were calling me
white devil they were calling me crazy
and [ __ ] like I'm talking about natural
laws of the universe I'm talking about
intention I'm talking about all this
[ __ ] that seemed crazy no and it feels
good now to be like I know it sounded
crazy but that [ __ ] was real yeah yeah
yeah so I'm just trying to keep like
we've been talking about it like two
three weeks ago I gotta make a new
vision board it's time to reset these
goals exactly so let's go I'm in the
process of doing that right now and just
seeing what happens nice yeah yeah and
the overall goal the whole show I hope
every single person that watches can
starts to grow as we go we're like
homies like we're homies with these
people we see them they see us they're
virtual friends like we say and in this
hope like those comments keep rolling in
like yo I got that job but it's just
like little Olivia at the show like that
spark had that spark I mean her whole
life could go on a different direction
yeah that's that could be for that's
what we're hoping for every viewer yeah
you get that spark and it's like damn
that's in there now because you know
that's all it takes that's all it takes
your life can go off in a completely
different direction we're all alive
you're healthy you got it that's it got
nothing to whine about exactly and with
your Dream Foundation what's the next
step
I mean I think the next step is
is going to be not so much like
playing the game but like dominating
like making making a a movement so big
that
we really shift shift culture like the
same way we shift the culture and
Hip-Hop which seems easy because it's
entertainment but then in philanthropy
that doesn't seem so easy but how do you
make it entertainment to where it truly
is because like we'll upload a video
right now and we'll be able to fundraise
a hundred thousand dollars for a little
girl with cancer within 10 hours like
that's the power of using the crowd and
entertaining and understanding how these
algorithms work but not for like vanity
but more for like let's change this
little girl's life y'all so it's like
we're at the we're ushering in a new era
of philanthropy the same way we ushered
in a new era of hip-hop
um so really like I see YouTube as the
biggest thing to where my brain I know
my brain works
as big if not bigger than
even like a Mr Beast who thinks really
big but like but that's how my brain
works so it's like when I think about
little Olivia
it's like
how do we make our million dollars in
three weeks and that's the first level
of the video game
like where I'll be
six years from now is like
okay
it's not make her a million dollars in
three weeks it's
make her a hundred million dollars and
we're global distribution through every
h m or every you know and then it's like
okay then we're partnering with Nike and
this and it's at every store so it's
like there's this ladder that like you
think about like Mr Beast has climbed
the ladder of just dreaming big and he
just you know climbs it I'm gonna do
that but for other people to where it's
not just me okay I'm gonna bring on this
concept called The Dream 100 where now
there's not just me now there's a
hundred of me and this is a real Army of
Love now when I look at like a Titan in
the game I look at like a Make-a-Wish
for example make a wish that's 10 000
wishes a year wow that's a lot right
but they raised 239 million to do that
I'm like that's a lot of money to do ten
thousand which is which is great I love
what they do but then I was like
if I had a hundred
people in the army
it did two dreams a week
it's ten thousand
it's not hard a hundred so I'm going to
formula dream 100 and I'm gonna show
donors that like okay we don't need to
spend 239 million dollars
to make Ten Thousand Dreams Come True we
could do it for 20 million
because we're using creators we're using
social media we're like that new
Innovative so it's like Step One is
YouTube step two is like dream 100
then it's like where we're at in five
years from now it's like okay how do we
do a Million Dreams in a year
okay let's keep scaling you know so
that's that's what I'm that's what I'm
trying to do and I'm trying to do it in
the biggest way possible bigger than
anything I ever done bigger than music
bigger than the Nike stuff coolest I
ever heard man absolutely spreading
positivity globally
other than yourself is the most selfless
thing you could do so I [ __ ]
appreciate that and making positivity
cool is the number one step like yo yeah
you look sick you help out because we
want to do the beach cleanups like dude
do something and then do something to
like make your community
I just literally got a text message yo
y'all gonna think I made this up
because I'm doing a podcast I did not
make it up I got a text message from my
boy p
he takes me Langford and Timmy
um he said I have a kid he sent this at
11 35 by the way
he said I have a kid his name is Reggie
he's down bad
in a bad situation and environment
highly intuitive kid very wise and smart
but he's hurting he has a voice he wants
to be a motivational speaker to help
kids like him I feel like he could have
his own podcast
he's a really captivating kid he's 15
years old he's in a bad place
what if we made a dream come true
together
helped them launch a podcast we do a
whole thing rally everybody
and we make a dream come true us three I
love that but in the biggest way let's
think about the biggest ideas what could
be who's this first guest you see what
I'm saying like how could we see what
you're saying see like we got to think
so big that now it's fun
launching podcast be like oh here's a
little equipment hold on big is fun and
sometimes big is even easier so what if
we made a dream come true together a
podcast and dream
but we really launched that thing into
the stratosphere
he's his first guest is out of here but
we teach him we you know so yeah he
could inspire a lot of other kids if we
talked about it recently because we had
a meet and greet and these kids were
like yo we can start a podcast to go
start a [ __ ] podcast there's no
podcast for people under 20. there's no
pockets of a 15 year old going out there
like perspective from me you know how
many fans you'll have who's on the
internet [ __ ] kids the most yeah
who's gonna flock to the kid speaking
his mind [ __ ] kids the most who's
gonna show up at the meet and greets
your kids who's gonna buy the shirt
[ __ ] kids their parents money maybe
but I was just talking about this like a
podcast for somebody that's not an adult
would be so [ __ ] massive because
that's the main population on YouTube
now they can be like Oh I'm 15. I always
got LeBron James on his show like
there's so many things like I'm inspired
I can do it and I can do something
of course we're going to make a big
dream whatever you want to do um is he
from L.A yeah easier he's in L.A
you would have thought I plan this mid
episode well when I went to go use the
restroom I was checking my text messages
and I mean it didn't even hit me until
just now though like I didn't I read it
and I'm like oh I want to help him and
as I was sitting down thinking about
this I was like and if we made a dream
come true in the biggest way possible we
need to think of the biggest things we
could do so I can't wait to do a
brainstorming session
let's think of biggest things to set his
career up because if the if every kid
whoever wanted a podcast sees him do it
they'll believe exactly man and tune in
yeah for real like and [ __ ] tune the
shyest kid it takes you talk to the shot
kid once [ __ ] opens right up that was
me talk to me man I don't talk to
[ __ ] if you talk to me hey I
talk a lot I just don't want to initiate
that was me as a kid yeah like breaking
that first step was so hard and if
somebody just helped me but you know
it's not it's [ __ ] you're looking back
on your former self like damn that kid
was [ __ ] shy that's weird thinking
about it now but that shy kid might be
two years later be us talking walking
around like doing [ __ ] so yes appreciate
you have our information let's see it
does do it in February after after I go
run it up for this little girl exactly
because we we're moving this week so
yeah so like sometime mid-February let's
do a big drink okay all right that's
[ __ ] sick Bro like that's really
that's pretty cool man I'm down stuff
we've been talking about this is cool
dude we talked about recently there
needs to be a show for kids that for
kids hey nice thing you know you have a
little podcast Network
you talked about that recently too let's
go no dude thank you so much and right
now how can everybody support if there's
a [ __ ] billionaire out there it's
like the Dream Foundation how could be a
part of it how do they get in contact
with anybody in your team yeah how does
this work
um
it's pretty easy to find us uh Charlie
on Instagram Charlie on Tick Tock
Charlie rocket on YouTube the number one
thing I'm gonna ask y'all to do is if
you see
something we're doing
get involved like it could be simple
like if you watch our YouTube video
that's a form of donation simple because
you don't have like you could literally
just watch it and it's going to help
people because we take that money in we
help people every day so it's like just
helping us help more people
if you see a fundraiser link you want to
donate a dollar a thousand dollars just
do it share if you can't donate but
that's all I ask is energy
money is energy effort is energy talking
to somebody else about it is energy but
um whether you want to hop on this
movement now or you want to hop on in 30
years I'm still going to be doing the
same thing so it's like I would love for
people to join the Army of Love that's
all I want like we're out here
every day so if you want to join come on
now come on later whatever
there's a we just we just want people's
energy that's it I can appreciate you
man the message and everything dude this
is I honestly I'm one of my favorite
yeah I'm just gonna say that for real
like I really [ __ ] love this thank
you for coming through and giving us
your time because I know you got [ __ ] to
do so thank you very much so for
everyone out there Charlie on everything
except Charlie Brockett on Instagram on
YouTube Charlie rocket we'll pop it all
up on the screen too but yeah anything
else you want to say really appreciate
this and I I really looking forward to
doing that in February and probably a
bunch of other stuff in the future too
yeah just let us know man that sounds
great all right we have a I have a brand
called the dopest yeah that's
alternative Canada movie brand but we're
trying
give a car here help us full here you
got a nursing school help this so
whatever you can do we're [ __ ] down
this is what me and my partners are
always trying to do many a story so if
y'all were trying to do to ever do that
I got tons I got John that's what he
does every day is like they just did
their first charity act in the
Philippines for Toys for Tots yeah we're
just trying to do like yeah bro like
people are bringing the money like we
don't need all of it let's [ __ ] spent
like I want to whatever we can do what
you're doing you have the infrastructure
of us like how can we help today yeah
yeah so yeah this is great this is
[ __ ] perfect thank you very much of
course this is a good episode thank you
very much for coming today hey thank
y'all thank you everybody go follow go
support uh like I said we always say it
even liking is support it helps watching
is support so go help and support
something that's Entertainment and by
the way you're helping the world change
people's lives all around the world so
thank you so much Marty thank you for
everything Charlie thank you for giving
us your time guys this has been the
dope's usual podcast have a dope ass day
yeah dude love this you can
perfect